warning if you watch this video to the
end and follow these strategies
step by step there's a high probability
that
you will make money with youtube and
online
in fact if you're just starting youtube
or you have a small channel
i'm going to be talking about the best
way to start earning money without the
youtube adsense program so you don't
have to worry about getting 1 000
subscribers or 4 000 hours of watch time
first
and we're going to be looking at really
the state of the
creator economy and i'm gonna be talking
about five youtube video ideas
that you can do today to make money that
are easy to implement
i'm gonna talk about some of my personal
results and show you what this can lead
to
and also how to start a profitable side
hustle online with xero experience but
look at this
a ceo the ceo from youtube recently
released a letter
and it revealed that the youtube economy
is incredibly healthy and strong despite
the challenges of 2020
and that the number of new channels that
joined the youtube partner program
more than doubled over the year before
in
2020 now you don't even have to join the
youtube partner program to use the
strategy i'm going to show you in this
but this is what i want you to see
creators are building the next
generation of media companies i'm
quoting youtube ceo
that impact the economy's overall
success according to an
oxford economics report youtube's
creative ecosystem contributed
approximately 16 billion dollars to the
u.s gdp in 2019
that's the equivalent of 345 000
jobs in the uk 30 000
full-time jobs equivalent in france 15
000 full-time jobs equivalent and i
share that
because here at think media we are on a
mission
to help 10 000 people create a full-time
living doing what they love with
youtube and signalfire revealed that
this is the fastest growing small
business type
and so it is crazy what is happening
with the youtube economy the creator
economy
and the strategies i'm going to be
breaking down in this video i believe
are the absolute best way to get started
but hey if we're just meeting my name is
sean cannell
and i'm the founder of think media and
we're going to actually be talking about
affiliate
marketing the best way to start earning
money on youtube without
the youtube adsense program if you're
fired up
hit the like button and let's talk about
tip number one this is a specific type
of video you can do
to start earning money right away and
that is a specific
product review here's what i mean you
actually create a video and you review
a specific product and so in this video
i was talking about a lighting kit
called the newer 660
lights and uh this video has done very
well
not only was helping people find a
budget lighting kit not only
do i explain how the lighting kit works
and compare it to others but i have
earned a lot of money
through the amazon associates program
and i'll explain what that is in just a
second
through doing a specific product review
i've been doing this for years
years ago on my channel sean cannell i
reviewed
a power bank by real juice and that's
another example on that same channel
i've done i've reviewed cbd oil i've
reviewed christmas cards
with my wife uh did you know you could
sign up for an affiliate program for
something like
mix book and they do holiday cards
and i we're like this is our cards this
is uh you know the pictures we picked
this is how we use the software link in
the description down below
and we earned hundreds of dollars from
doing a specific
product product review now if you're new
to affiliate marketing this is the
foundational strategy
you're using youtube which is a search
engine and a very powerful algorithm
with suggested videos and you're using
affiliate
marketing affiliate marketing is when
you review or recommend a product online
and you earn a commission when someone
purchases that product here's my
definition it's a cool way
to make money sharing products you love
and use
and maybe you've had friends or you've
thought before oh
is that some internet marketer scamming
guy i don't like the word marketing
listen chill out you i assume you're
watching this video
and you're adding value you're serving
people this is a cool way
to make money listen sharing products
that you already love and use
just like you'd recommend them to a
friend it does not make the products
cost more money
so instead of the big corporation amazon
making more money
the creator gets a piece and everybody
wins
the product creator wins amazon wins the
creator wins
and i know you're going to be doing this
in integrity and recommending great
products that will help
people's lives so the person who gets a
product wins
they avoid the bad product they get the
good product they
actually find the thing that fits their
specific needs best
and so that's my definition of affiliate
marketing and here's how it works you
can sign up for something like the
amazon
affiliate program and i've got four more
strategies in just a second
but you can sign up united kingdom
germany france japan canada china
italy spain india brazil mexico
but this isn't the only affiliate
program you can sign up for dick's
sporting goods target walmart nordstrom
a lot of software companies and you also
don't have to live in the country that
you're
promoting from it really just matters
where your viewers are we have a lot of
students
in some of our programs that live around
the world
but their most of their affiliate income
comes from the us
amazon associates program and the canada
amazon associates program
even though they don't live here the
money is generated here and then they
wire it
to themselves through setting all that
up on the back end
and so what you do is you can sign up
for any affiliate program
then it gives you the ability to create
trackable links which you can put in
your youtube description
and when some visitors click those links
and they purchase something you get paid
now we're not going to go into uh just
the fact that of course you always want
to tell people
that you have links in the description
down below their affiliate links or make
disclaimers in your description down
below
it is important that again you're
transparent with all this stuff and here
in america we have what's called the ftc
uh and so you want to make sure you're
in compliance there and in a little
while later i'm going to show you how
much
i earned today off the amazon associates
program but let's get into i've got five
total tips
the first one was do specific product
reviews the second one on youtube
is do best of uh
or top product review videos okay here's
an example
the best greens powder
now greens powder something you mix with
water
when you're traveling so you have your
greens that you you need to stay healthy
i'm kind of into biohacking and uh all
kinds i
invest a lot in supplements and whatnot
so again it was a product i use
i tried i recommended and this video is
generated over ten thousand dollars
this was not through amazon it's through
a different affiliate program but again
people don't know necessarily the
product name yet so you might say the
best
fill in your niche and the products you
talk about the best
yoga mat for tall people you know like
whatever it is and so
best now best could also here's another
example best camera and equipment for
youtube beginners
think about it they're not searching for
a specific
product they don't know about the newer
660 like
lights yet the person is searching for a
category
so it's the best camera or equipment for
youtube beginners
here's another one best self-improvement
books not even just
book best books but what's the specific
category so
four years ago i did best
self-improvement books seven best
self-help books and just recently on our
podcast which i hope you're subscribed
to on apple and spotify in google
and youtube it's called the think
marketing podcast
um i did five must must-read books if
you want to grow on youtube the category
was books you should read if you want to
grow on youtube
and in both cases in the description
there is affiliate links to the books
this is the absolute best way to start
making money on youtube because you
don't
need to be approved for the adsense
program you don't need to hit
4 000 hours of watch time you can start
doing this early on now maybe not from
absolutely day one and i'll give you
more information about when i think you
should start
later but uh let's keep it rocking
here's another example top best or top
top five best strollers 2021
budget stroller systems and more best
strollers 2020
up a baby come on i'm a new dad i got a
four month old so this is the world that
i've been living in i now have my thule
jogging stroller my favorite item that i
own so i can take my son
out on runs but let's keep it going so
we have
you know top or best now here's the
third category
and here's the deal if you make these
videos and you put out good content and
you pick strategic
we can't even get into you should do
some keyword research you should
research
the products themselves you should see
if there's interest you know make sure
you're subscribed because we have topics
that will help you in the other areas
but when you do this right and you
connect it
rightly to affiliate marketing this will
make you money and if you want to work
from home and write your own checks and
be your own boss
you could see how powerful this is right
so tip number three versus videos
canon g7x mark iii versus mark two
perfect example of someone who's like
okay should i get the new one
should i get the old one there's
actually searching for that exact
question
unfortunately the g7x mark iii's
autofocus is not good
other than that it's great at
photography but if you had to pick one
and you wanted to vlog with it i'd still
recommend the mark ii
see to pass along information like that
you're helping people right you're
serving people now
best camera for youtube notice i'm
combining titles here
best camera for youtube canon m50 versus
the sony zb1
it's it's what's the category as well as
two different cameras
compared so you could do you know the
332 dollar blender versus the 53
blender that has 136 000 views from
honest reviews
vitamix versus ninja or chef austin's
review
vitamix versus ninja so you can do
affiliate marketing in
every kind of niche for all types of
different products it doesn't just have
to be tech
right it could be health it could be
makeup it could be skin care
it could be books it could be software
however it is important that you don't
get too romantic about it
and wish and become idealistic that i
just can't think of any products in my
niche you may actually want to pick a
niche
that would be more profitable like if
it's your vision
to be full-time serve people help people
but support your family
and be able to work from home on your
own terms like you got to be strategic
about it you got to think about
potentially what niche you want to be in
so if you're talking if you're doing
cooking
you're comparing pots and pans and
knives and you eventually
separate strategy but you sign up for
cutco and now you're in network
marketing too and you got links you're
building your team and you're comparing
kitchen products
and you're also talking about
subscription boxes and blue apron and
all kinds of stuff there's so many
different ways
to earn money tip number four hit like
if you're getting value
ideas list video so now
this isn't even assuming check this out
that you even have a product sean
what if i don't have a product that i
can review yet
what if i don't actually have two things
that are verses
did you know you can just share a list
of ideas you could even share a list of
ideas
and pull some b-roll meaning some
footage
off of uh product trailers or some
pictures
off of websites showing the products
that are the list of ideas i've seen
people do this with products that they
do not own
so eight years ago i made a video called
gift
ideas for him okay so it's not a review
it's not verses it's not the top i'm not
even saying they're the best
just saying their ideas like do you need
some gift
ideas for the man in your life and in
this case i just gather some stuff from
around the house
and i like some headphones and like a
watch and some books
and my gps at the time out of my car i
was like you could get them a gps
you know it doesn't have to be the gps
yours might be a couple
uh years older i linked i linked to
current i'm like this one's a little bit
older but there's a great deal happening
right now on amazon on a newer one you
can check it out link in the description
down below
you're just kind of pointing to ideas i
was using artifacts
to like signal things like yeah you
could give them a book here's a couple
book recommendations but i'll link some
others in this
like it's just ideas trying to help
somebody that's doing some research
imagine having a video out like this
around black friday cyber monday and the
holidays maybe you can see the
connection
that this is the fastest and best way to
start making money
on youtube right like even if you're
just starting and what i did was then i
went deeper on the topic cool christmas
gift ideas tech
gift guide top 10 tech gift ideas
gift ideas for creative people gift
ideas for him
is this ridiculous best tech gifts gift
ideas for men my wife
gift ideas for women gift ideas for her
you can see like we were
thorough like going deep on these
various
topics and uh because again i had a
clear vision
of like okay let me answer a specific
question and a specific problem which i
was doing
let me do research here's the thing i
mean i wasn't taking shortcuts on these
videos like i wanted them to be good
content
content is king but marketing is queen
and she runs the household
and i was putting out good content
and this is how originally i was able to
quit my job and go full time on youtube
before ever teaching about it or
anything else right
so tip number five uh and then after
this i want to share the biggest mistake
though because these won't work
if you do the mistake especially over
the long haul plus
my friend chalene johnson uh is got a
really cool way
with 10 additional ways to make money
without adsense
she's got a cool like challenge thing
coming up i'll tell you about that and
i'm going to show you my amazon
associates earnings
and i'm going to answer questions about
this very topic on the coffee with
kennel show which i forgot to introduce
okay
tip number five asq answer specific
questions this one will blow your mind
so i made a video called verismo pods
cheap
do cbtl pods work in a starbucks verismo
so first of all this is a specific
question like incredibly specific
like so i got a starbucks barista it's
kind of like a keurig
do cbtl pods work in a starbucks free
smoke
and i'll tell you this story like so
this was given to me as a gift
when i was working at a church as a
campus pastor from the senior pastors
we're like awesome we love coffee this
is amazing we can make it fast
and i like various smells better than
keurigs okay no do you like keurigs do
you like verismos or do you actually
care about the environment let me know
in the comments
so uh i'm i'm looking at the verismo we
get it
but we noticed that the pods for it from
starbucks cost like as much
as a venti mocha
triple shot extra whipped cream
frappuccino
and so we're like this is this is not
saving money these pods are so expensive
so we go over our friend rachel and
henry's house they've got the same
machine the verismo
so like okay cool we open the drawer
they're like want some coffee
to my shock a ghast i look at the drawer
and i'm like
what kind of pods are these these little
these little pinkish
you know and yellow and i'm like those
aren't starbucks pods like what are we
talking about
they're like they're cbtl pods i'm like
what the heck is that
coffee bean tea leaf i'm like what the
heck is that
so hey uh so so they go yeah these
they fit perfectly they work in this
machine even though they're not made by
starbucks
i'm like where in the world did you get
them to go we order them directly from
the cbtl website
so i go huh because i'd already been
doing affiliate marketing and answering
questions
and as soon as you identify a problem
you then can start thinking about how
you could solve or answer that problem
on youtube
and you could actually profit from a
problem this is what entrepreneurs do is
they solve problems for a profit
by answering a question helping people
and monetizing in the middle with
affiliate marketing so
i go well maybe these cbto pods are on
amazon
so i go home i'm so pumped like sonya's
like why are you so in a frenzy i'm like
i just geek out about this youtube and
you know affiliate marketing type stuff
let's see what sure enough there's cbtl
pods on amazon order order order amazon
prime boom ship them to my house
test them out delicious the coffee is
good
and the price is even better and you can
get them from amazon better than some
other weird website because people are
already signed up and they got amazon
prime and it's already happening you get
it
so now i'm like well let me turn this
into a video
answer specific questions so i answer
the question
which is searched so i do my keyword
research verismo pods cheap do
cbtl pods work in very small now notice
this is a seven-year-old video as 153
000 views the person that is looking for
this
is wanting to answer that question
curious and notice i've got my little
disclaimer here amazon links are
affiliate links you can see that right
there
and i'm like yo are you curious
opening of the video if these pods work
in verismo well i'm here to tell you
we're going to do a test right now i'm
going to show you we're also going to
taste test the coffee i got my friends
miguel and abby over and so i make a
little video it's 6 minutes and 55
seconds
long my friends i have been selling
coffee
on autopilot through affiliate marketing
for seven years
every month i sell coffee because of
this one videos can you see how go crazy
because i answered a specific question i
really scratch my own itch because
notice this was the overflow
of the products i love and use ooh i
discovered something like oh cool i
found something out let me pass along
that information now
this is important to know because when
someone clicks an amazon affiliate link
for 24 hours anything they buy
during that 24 hours after they clicked
your link
gets credited to you so even though a
box of these pods is like 10 bucks or 15
bucks
when someone clicks that link and they
buy that new set
of jeggings and they buy you know those
bonk
queen nails and they buy that
playstation 5 for whoever
you get credit for that as well so when
you start putting out smart and
strategic
videos like this you could make this
video
day one on your youtube channel you
could like
and when you if you can find the right
questions the answer and you answer
specific questions
and you connect it to smart monetization
strategies then what ends up happening
is you're asking you're answering a
specific question with the video and the
product
is the answer right and it in this case
it's a great example
because it is a win-win-win-win-win cbtl
pods
people save money cbt on you know not
having to buy verismo
cbtl is pumped amazon's making sales
they're pumped
the person who finds this out is like i
can save money you know
they're pumped the end user gets more
coffee options and then i'm earning
money in the process helping support my
son
helping support my family and helping us
live the life
around you know with a business built
around our lifestyle where we really
have
freedom and financial freedom in
the process and listen this is just one
way to earn money on youtube so hit like
i've got some more stuff to share with
you but i did want to tell you about
this
because you got to think different if
you want to get different results and
potentially create a shorter path to
revenue
than even others are experiencing all
anyone ever talks about is youtube
adsense like i gotta get monetized
i gotta get a thousand subs cool like
let's do it i gotta get four thousand
hours of watch like okay
but there's other ways to do this if you
think outside of the box and one of the
best
people i know for ways to make money
online and starting a side hustle and
thinking outside of the box
is my friend chalene johnson so i just
want to put this on your radar she's got
a
five day free challenge we've done a
couple challenges before hers is
different
it's a side hustle challenge she's gonna
be talking about 10 ways to make money
online
um it's that idea to income dot tips if
you want to check it out link in the
description down below
now this particular uh challenge
is brock johnson who we just had on the
think marketing podcast
brett johnson they're breaking it down
and chalene has actually been a personal
mentor of mine that's why i wanted to
introduce her to you
so i encourage you it's starting maybe
soon depending on when you're watching
this but
you got a couple days totally free five
day challenge
to think outside of the box and come up
with
multiple different ways outside of
youtube adsense for making money and you
can use youtube for the traffic
and awareness so just head to idea to
income dot tips if you want to sign up
for the free fry
five day challenge with chalene but i
told you i was gonna tell you the
biggest mistake and here's the biggest
mistake that hurts you with this
focusing on money too soon and not
leading with value and service okay
so listen you know i know that i was
like you could start
and you should start from the day one
which i think is fine
if you find a video like the cbtl video
i did because it's very practical and
connected to affiliate marketing but
what i've noticed there's really kind of
two things
that really hurt people is they focus on
money too
soon like if you come right out the gate
just like oh how do i make the most
money how do i just find something
like people can sense that like you have
to lead i believe
with value and service we say influence
comes first
income comes second so you don't want to
focus on money too soon
you got to lead with value you got to
lead with service
and i think that as you build up your
influence
in answer to the specific question of
how much how much view should i have how
big should my channel be to do affiliate
marketing
i would recommend you probably have 10
to 20 videos posted
your channels in a particular niche and
you're getting around 200 views per
video
just so there's a little bit of momentum
when you start this now
if you really know the strategies
meaning you're making the right videos
like if you do
the five videos i just taught you and if
you're somehow just joining the video
right now make sure to watch
the replay if you do the five videos i
taught you
they will do well like they just if you
can find a good product and do a versus
video or you can do a top list or a best
list
and you do it about something that's
maybe not been covered or hasn't been
covered in the current year yet
you have a lot of opportunity to get the
traffic and the momentum needed
to get enough qualified amazon sales and
there's so many other affiliate programs
so i just want to encourage you
avoid focusing on money too soon i want
you to know the strategy
but i think you should start without
like well i'm not approved for an
affiliate program yet post the videos
anyways like
get on youtube start adding value start
getting comfortable with
making videos punch fear in the face
punch perfectionism in the face
and press record and i know i told you
i'll share where this led for us
now of course these results are not
typical and i'm not suggesting that
anybody who follows this advice are
gonna get these results
and you might just get zero results
because i don't know if you're gonna
take action
but in january of 2021
i earned thirty thousand three hundred
and ninety two dollars and nineteen
cents off the amazon associates program
so if you're curious like where could
this scale to
dude that's some life's changing money
you know what i mean like that's that in
one month
now because of showing doing the
strategies i just showed you and doing
them year after year
video after video and perfecting really
a system
to get these results i share this
not just to flex although i really
understand that this is a flex
is that to show you that it's just real
that like
if you keep working the strategies and
you keep persisting and you keep
doubling down on good content and you
keep building trust and you make the
right videos
like this isn't just this can learn and
we're a part of
like 25 different affiliate programs
this is just
amazon and this is just one of over 10
different income streams in the business
so when you hear that the youtube
economy is blowing up
and i want to disclaimer like think
media now is a team
so this is a team effort that's
producing these big numbers we got 13
people that are are helping it think
media but don't get it
twisted i started this freaking thing in
my bedroom
by myself with the camera alone
talking to myself and into the lens and
hoping somebody was on the other side
just like you
and video after video discouraging up
high
highs and lows year after year i just
want to encourage you just don't quit
keep learning this stuff implement this
stuff and put this into practice
like actually do these five videos as i
explained do the research
and you'll be blown away with the
results you can get okay we're gonna do
some q a
in just a second but uh reminder idea
income dot tips this is just one way
so i remember uh i've spoke at shalene
johnson's event a couple times we've
gone snowboarding and whatnot she's
really like a big sister to me um and i
love her stuff it's really helped us
grow our business
and i mentioned we have 10 different
income streams i mean she's teaching the
top 10 ways to make money online this
year
so anyways free challenge five days this
is a no miss event idea to income dot
tips check that out
i'm excited to be checking it out and
always learning the latest stuff that
chalene is on link in the description
down below coffee with kennel how are
you
i forgot to introduce the show earlier
maybe i kind of did i had a picture of
it
but hit the like button let me know what
you're sipping on and uh
i'm excited to get into this we're gonna
bring on some folks today
answer some questions and um
smash like if you're getting value and
we have oliver coming up
in just a second but uh i hope you're
doing well
can you believe it's already the second
month of the year i can't all right
uh oliver my man how's it going um
what's up with you remind people about
your channel and uh what's been up man
what's going on
hey sean awesome to to be here can you
actually hear me fine
yeah i can hear you great uh so yeah hi
everyone my name is oliver um
my channel is is called road to finish
and uh on the channel i
i talk about education and early career
development specifically in finland
and my mission is to help international
students to
get their degree and get their career
started specifically in finland and uh
as you guys do as well i actually
specified my
my vision this week and i really want to
help during the
my career i want to help 10 000 people
to actually
go through this path and actually get
their career started in finland so
that's been that's more specific
specific now compared to last year
i'm actually doing uh great and uh just
first of all i wanted to say congrats on
the baby
i'm a bit late to the party but i just
wanted to say that out loud i hope
the family is doing great and um
uh also full time just so people get it
clear you went full time
at like how many subs yeah i was just uh
just actually about to
to mention that i again i wanted to
thank you for for
all the all the valuable tips so i think
we spoke the last time early last year
was it april
april ish when i was actually furloughed
from my
nine to five in in uh uh
uh social media marketing and um
i when when we last time spoke i told
you that i will be going full time with
a
channel that had 2500 subscribers ish
and i actually took the plunge in
september and
uh i was maybe at 25 50 or something
like that
and i've been full-time since september
1st
and uh now i have around 5 500
subscribers
and uh doing actually really well and um
my question actually is is about
diversifying one's
income streams and now that i'm i'm
actually able to work on this full-time
and um i actually i got some really
really good advice from heather
last week again thanks for those as well
but i wanted to drill a bit deeper into
the topic with you
so my question is i'm starting my
first paid course
uh in in the next coming upcoming months
and i was just wondering because i'm
starting to also build my email list i'm
a bit late to the party here as well
but i was wondering what are the biggest
lessons that you guys have had in terms
of
email lists and email automation when it
comes to selling
digital products yeah that's a
uh a great question so one of the most
important things to
sync the room is you want to be building
your email list and it's kind of a
little known talked about thing for
youtube creators
especially as algorithms change as you
never know what's going to happen
um with any kind of algorithm or
platform
and you'll notice pat flynn's i just
noticed uh schmittastic
amy landino is a great example like you
you want to pay attention to what people
are doing and
on her channel which is about
productivity and whatnot on her
community tab
she's kind of got this thing going like
one a weekly email for me and you gotta
wonder
why is she doing that well because it's
a place to take the conversation deeper
but it's also maybe
she maybe her videos aren't reaching her
audience or whatever so
punchline is you want to build an email
list even more so
especially if you're going to sell
something or you have a product it gives
you that chance to
um a key point oliver and and coffee
with kennel crew
is you know google revealed that if you
actually want to sell something
there used to be the law of 7 in
marketing meaning somebody needed
seven touch points just to be reminded
about purchasing something it's gen
because we're so busy too you're like
yeah that looks pretty cool i want that
and then your kid runs into the room and
like knocks your coffee on your lap and
like burns your crotch you're like ah
and then you like forget to
because like life's so crazy then then
you need another reminder and a lot of
times
when we buy stuff it's when we get that
like black friday sale is ending i'm
like oh that's right i needed to get
that jacket like that was so dope
so when you have an email list and
someone's on your email list
you also have the chance this is to your
answer your question
i think a couple key things is people
don't email enough
once they've signed up for the list
they're raising their hand especially if
it's
related to the value you're going to
provide in your course
you want to actually probably email more
than most one of the biggest mistakes
people make is they start building their
email list and they're afraid to email
their list
they're also afraid someone's going to
unsubscribe someone's always going to
unsubscribe
they're afraid like you know people
unfollow me every day
on instagram people unsubscribe from me
every day
on youtube i've lost hundreds of
thousands of subscribers how crazy is
that you want to talk about rejection
like i've been rejected by over a
hundred thousand people
on think media wow that'll that'll put
you in counseling so
i i think uh don't be afraid to email
your list
i think i you need to study um
copywriting you know what you probably
are which is but
but also uh storytelling story selling
you want to be like telling stories and
adding value in every email
one of the the keys to email marketing
is that when someone sees an email from
you number one
maybe they know that there's gonna be
something for sale
but they know that whenever they see
your name your email
that they're gonna get value on the
other side
so hopefully that's the same on youtube
hopefully that's the brand i'm trying to
build too it's like if you see me upload
it you might even know that i'm going to
be like
hey yo uh we got a new thing or like get
my book like you might know that
like like yeah sean he's kind of he will
probably talk about his book
but hopefully also like he always adds
value and you want to
put that into the email so you've been
creating videos but you want to be
thinking about man how do i add value
maybe i unpack something in words and i
start to
share the story and so uh you know
we've studied a lot of you can hit
heather up or or dml on instagram
we have a whole our favorite books our
favorite courses
on like copywriting and email marketing
our friend pat flynn is
is uh very influential in a lot of that
stuff and um
i think that's a huge key is then
thinking about that and then finally you
mentioned auto responders
but for those that are new to email
marketing
get response or mailchimp or kajabi or
click funnels or whatever
gives you the chance to set up an
autoresponder which is the dream
of how this works like the way you can
build a business around your lifestyle
is number one
let's break the whole thing down quickly
you rank a video on youtube
it's showing up and suggested it's
showing up in search in this very video
i shared videos about cbtl pods that are
seven years old and so getting views
so a video is getting views now imagine
in that same video
you give a call to action for someone to
join your email list
be it an email newsletter a free class a
free download a free checklist
whatever so someone signs up for that
they enter their email
that triggers another automated process
when we break down that you should do
storytelling story selling copywriting
and actually putting a ton of energy
writing the greatest email sequence
like in a way you want to write an email
sequence that's as good as a book
or better that's like it's a page turner
like
man i want to just keep chapter one was
good chapter two is good i can't wait
till chapter three shows up in my inbox
tomorrow like
thinking about that and there's other
things like not only you should email
another autoresponder four hours after
they opt in and just say hey just did
you get it make sure to add me to safe
senders and different things to avoid
spam filters and
kind of a lot to get in here i know i'm
throwing a lot out there but as we land
the plane what
ends up happening is you may have 10
days of an email follow-up sequence
you may have one a week for four weeks i
know people who have a year's worth of
follow-up
in their email sequence can we get a
bomb emoji in the comments right now
like the head explode think about this
a video is getting views while you're on
vacation with your
family at the end of that video someone
signs up for your email list
at that point a year's worth of follow
up happens in automation
it's not some wasted you know
crap content it's valuable the entire
time
and if you think about building no like
and trust trust and nurturing
it's kind of like someone reading your
book like
they're they're hearing stories they're
getting value they're
you know learning more about you and
from the very beginning
you could do this sometimes you could be
more direct about your product and other
times just do a ps
you're like p.s uh you know if you
actually want to just jump in right now
i
i over the next 30 days i'm going to be
like adding value in your inbox
but like the best move is to join my
thing because that's going to give you
all the answers
right now jump in and ps
and that's super chill you can always
just have the ps down there and then
maybe
eventually in the sequence you're able
to share stories of student success
and kind of a million other things so
that was sort of a fire hose of
email marketing strategy but was that
helpful oliver
definitely yeah and uh actually funny
thing with that what you mentioned about
creating a email autoresponder
in bulk it's it's basically i think that
a lot of people are afraid of email
marketing because
they personally hate emails as do i
however you think about email marketing
and autoresponders it's basically the
same thing as doing video content
you're doing creating content that's
just mentioned copy but it's not video
and you guys talk about batch producing
all the time
it's the same thing you batch produce
your emails for a month or a per year
so you know of course if you think about
it as a part of your content strategy
then
then it's easier to approach it um but
yeah definitely that that was really
helpful
awesome bro well i appreciate you and
your story super inspiring uh
what's your channel again shout it out i
should check it out sure so i changed
the channel name just a while ago
because actually people were
uh telling me that they cannot find it
so road to finish
is the updated name and i have to say
while you're looking it up i have to say
that i almost fell out
of my chair uh a month ago when you were
talking about the uh sugar daddy method
or
oliver method i i think oliver method
we gotta post that one yeah i was so
pumped uh
when someone else brought that up and we
were talking about you i mean it's
inspiring man i mean the fact that
you've been so entrepreneurial and
creative
and you're proof of the youtube economy
um
of of being you know carving your own
path
biz deving in your world and uh to go
full time at such a low subscriber mount
i don't know
road to finish how do you spell it road
so road
two so just wrote two and finish so
finnish double n
if if you can't find it maybe youtube
hasn't indexed it yet i changed the name
two weeks ago oh yeah it's still the old
name but okay this is it right
yeah that's it yeah yeah videos about
higher education and career
early career development in finland 5
30 subscribers
but full time we don't have time to get
into all the methods and how
but it's the oliver method and oliver
i'm so pumped you're on coffee with
kennel check out his channel
and thanks so much for coming on the
show man thanks sean cheers
all right we have uh amy coming up in
just a second
and i just want to say thanks for being
here friends smash like if you've been
getting value
and if you've got a question i'll answer
some questions in between put four
question marks before
and after your question
and um we're gonna get going here in
a second um what does going full time
mean on youtube can you elaborate jake
that's a great question because it's
kind of a moving target
here's what i would recommend you have
to define what full-time means for you
if you're single 20 able to live on a
friend's couch pay him 300 bucks
a month in rent full time to you might
be earning 1 000
a month for food health care
a bus pass and the 300 rent so step one
how much money do you need to live on
per month and not to ball out
like jay-z in a big pimping yacht with
you know uh okay so
but like what do you practically need to
to live
because i think it's important to be
practical before you scale beyond that
and sometimes it's smart to scale back
your living
so that you can actually build a bright
future for yourself
as you're being entrepreneurial if
you're bootstrapping this side hustle
you know
my wife and i we kept we we continue to
but we've especially in light of where
we're at we are
we we stay conservative we stay lean and
mean because we always want to be
investing in our future but what's that
number just write that down what's that
number for you
do you live in the middle of downtown
manhattan you've got 15 kids
and so you need a pretty big apartment
you know condo down there
and so you need 25 000 a month just to
pay your rent
to keep those expensive garage two cars
in the garage
in the middle of new york city it
depends where you live right it depends
on your dependents it depends on
et cetera what's that number you need
secondly
it's when youtube or online income
has now produced that dollar amount for
you
so when you're in your side hustle
season you have some other primary
source of income a job
and that is what is paying your bills
for me i waited tables at red robin i've
worked at a church full-time
as the director of communications and my
side hustle was youtube and whether i
was earning 50 bucks a month
250 or 500 that was a side hustle
when i went into the solopreneur season
that was when my youtube
income met my needed monthly amount what
is your needed monthly amount of income
for us at the time and living in las
vegas with my wife and i
with our rent payment and with our other
bills
we needed around sixty thousand dollars
a year for both of us
with health insurance my wife has got
some different things we've battled over
the years so we knew that was our target
60 grand and in january
of 2016
i was earning i got a check for 4 500
from the amazon associates program and
around a thousand dollars from the
youtube adsense program so full-time for
me
was actually towards the end of 2015 and
by january of 2016
now if you do the math on that it's 60
grand a year
from youtube not not from having to go
to a job and show up at a certain time
now there's kind of a hype because even
the year before i was freelancing and
that's how some people do it i was
full-time off of youtube and i had
clients
three different clients and one paid me
2 000 and the other paid me 2001 paid me
1 000. so that was also
that's how i earned the 60k that year
but full time on youtube i would just
say is that you're able to more or less
you know work from home
work on your own terms and pay your
bills
whatever that number is for you and it's
probably different for everybody
and then finally there's the side hustle
season there's the
solopreneur season where it was just me
and my wife and we had enough money to
pay our bills but then there's the scale
season and let me know what season are
you in are you
in the side hustle season with youtube
are you in the solopreneur season are
you in the scale season
scale is where you're making more than
enough
and also scale i believe is that
eventually you start reinvesting in your
business so at those times
now i was hiring omar alta corey as a
contractor
uh back then and we had people like jay
and in those days
in those early days i met heather and we
were working together on building our
next thing which was actually our online
course and coaching program called video
ranking academy
and so we were going through the steps
of scaling
and scaling other people on and then
even having more than enough there's
something about hitting
just enough more than enough which you
could save invest
or waste or you could also reinvest it
in your business which has always been
our strategy
hiring other people getting better
faster computers cameras
going further faster i think that's your
smart bet the best investment you
can ever make i actually think is in
your own business
it's better than dogecoin or bitcoin
although the crypto people here
disagree with me um because you can
control your efforts and try to scale
your business so it can produce even
more that was a long answer
to what i think full-time means but when
we say full-time freedom and that's our
mission to help 10
000 people reach full-time freedom doing
what they love while making a difference
in the world with youtube and online
video
for some they love helping a particular
kind of person they love selling
stuff in their etsy shop they love uh
still
baking and actually selling cookies
in a local thing but also talking about
that on youtube and making online income
for some they're doing brand deals for
some they're doing affiliate marketing
for some it is a lot of adsense others
have created online courses
my friends there's so many paths and
that's also why i definitely recommend
going
to idea to income dot tips because
probably
my friend chalene johnson and brett
johnson and brock johnson's challenge
is probably the shortest path they're
going to break down the 10 different
ways
to reach full-time faster because the
slow route is definitely youtube ads if
that's the only thing
that you focus on
so much for rapid fire questions uh but
if you want to
learn a little bit more about that um
that's at idea to income dot tips and uh
we're gonna have amy
on the coffee with kennel show
uh amy tell me about your channel
cheers keep calm and drink coffee and uh
what do you do on youtube good morning
from hawaii where it's cool and rainy
not tropical and sunny
right now my channel is called frugal
over 50
and my tagline is that i give tips and
tools for frugal living all personally
tested
by me and i'm about to change the all
personally tested by me because my next
video coming up is about tips from the
great depression which i did not live
through so i didn't test them
i've been really fortunate because i had
a hobby channel
until may when you folks did the first
the first video influence challenge and
i was really fortunate to get in on that
and just jumped off of that into to
growing the channel and i got monetized
on adsense in september
and this is my latest video so
i am interested in this idea of
affiliate marketing because i have
dipped my toe
into it with some success because i'm in
the frugal living niche i feel like i
need to approach it somewhat delicately
because
i am i work in the group of people who
are the ones who walk into the store and
don't want anybody
coming and talking to them and they're
the people who read all the most
critical reviews before they make a
purchase
these are people who do shop and i have
made
some have had some success linking
with a couple of products that i use and
i have one that's a constant referral
link i talk about it all the time
and it gets me some um some
money back on a product that i myself
purchase
so i would like to do more things like
book recommendations on amazon or the
clothes that i just bought
for cheap or that sort of thing and my
question
is similar to oliver's about how to word
emails
how do i talk to
my sisters and brothers and others who
are like
i just want the most frugal thing and
i'm here so you can tell me how not to
spend money
but you're pushing a product on me and
this is getting sort of urgent because
my inbox as my channel grows is filling
with people who would like to work with
me and these are products that i
like like you know companies that sell
online courses
my audience is exactly the right target
audience for that
and i keep putting them off because i
don't even know how to word a video for
that
i tried it with a work at home computer
desk back in november
it was like crickets because i didn't i
didn't do it right i didn't approach my
viewers right so i don't have a review
channel i don't have a brand channel but
i have a growing channel in a niche
that's super popular and i'm really
happy with it
and i just know if i talk to them right
that i'll get the right people
so i am open to
scripts tips ideas uh
words of encouragement telling me to
just go for it and deal with it
whatever it takes so the definition of
frugal i heard from you first and
foremost just to clarify
is a simple or plain or costing
little so it's still costing something
but you will mention that in some cases
your audience almost wants to spend no
money they almost want the diy
so is it a little bit of both
yes it's it's definitely both when i
give tips and tools for frugal living
in some cases for instance one of my
most popular tips ever was
carry your own water bottle so we had a
big conversation about what's your
favorite water bottle it'd be great i
could link good water bottles on amazon
right
i missed that opportunity but i could
put it into another video this is the
kind of thing that we're dealing with
it's like
you spend money now to save later it's
about prioritizing how you spend
i just wanted to make sure because again
if the mentality was
i don't want to spend money at all well
then if there's no transaction there
could be no affiliate commission but
um here's a couple thoughts that i would
say i think that um
i think that there's something about
cadence
and we we talk about even potentially
the one in ten rule meaning
uh there's a book by gary vaynerchuk
called jab jab jab right hook
and it's a social media kind of youtube
philosophy
that the idea of jabbing is is value
value wow you didn't sell me anything
you didn't pitch me anything
but you gave me value that's an amazing
video i can go implement that my gosh
the value was so
good and that the right hook was it was
basically
give give give ask hey if you actually
want to potentially you know purchase
something
you've you've led with value first and
there's sort of that 75
of the time you're leading with value
and then 25 of the time you're
also trying to support you need money
for the mission you're inviting people
never pressuring people
into what they could do next with you
now it's a little bit different with
affiliate marketing potentially because
even on think media
our value is products like teaching
about the product showing the products
and in some senses affiliate marketing
really isn't a sale i don't view it as
it should be pushed
like a sale it actually is just as
education
and an invitation for people to
potentially learn more about it
but my point being is that
if you on your channel know your main
cadence is like
literally teaching people how to use
what they already have
and then every fourth video or every
tenth video
is a little bit more and never off-brand
for you but just a little bit more
direct in terms of even sponsored i mean
that might be something that would be
new to them but soon as you start
getting brand deals and like hey today's
video is brought to you by
um so i think number one cadence number
two i think
uh i think it's interesting to think
about ratucon or honey
um and those like website plugins i i
think um
a lot of times those people do brand
deals but there could be affiliate links
and those those scour the internet for
coupon codes
and help you find you know the best
price it almost could be a video that's
like
um you know tips for online shopping and
i'm the coupon code guy i'm always like
you know
insert brand name coupon code uh whereas
honey
scours the internet and just pulls the
coupon code for you
so the video can maybe have three tips
on coupon codes and can be brought to
you by honey and maybe
you biz dev and work out a brand deal
with them or there's an affiliate link
to sign up uh for them uh i think
other things related to coupons could be
interesting there might be like digital
coupons
but then i think amazon is the greatest
because to the point of
when someone clicks on a link to a book
it could be your favorite books on
frugal living it also could be books
about anything
um like like for an example you could go
to amazon
and even edu i'm sure most people know
about this but i never assume
people would know about this this is
freaking weird did amazon hear me say
jab jab or jab right hook because i
promised you i did not look at it
recently
and the audio all the time the robots
are coming
and it's this is not good so but
interestingly enough you know this book
is 21.99 for the hardcover
even if you were to educate your
audience hey you know uh here's a couple
books i recommend and you know did you
know that there's
like this used section like if you just
go to this new and use section
you can actually see that uh this is
acceptable for very good the book is 377
and four bucks shipping
so it ends up being like eight bucks
which is much cheaper than 22
and um i shop here all the time
and that insight might actually help
someone go oh dang i could pay eight
bucks for the book instead of 21
to to uh and and make sure and teach
them about the condition or whatever
keep in mind when you use an affiliate
link they've clicked over to amazon
and if they shop for even anything else
then you're going to get credit for that
which makes me think sometimes it could
just be
practical things if you were to do math
for people and show them that it's more
frugal to subscribe to toilet paper on
amazon and have it delivered
than it is buy it locally then you're
killing two birds with one stone
so if you're like here's the most frugal
path to
get these household goods that you're
going to use anyways and
check it out this is how i do it it's on
amazon then it's on brand for you and as
you build up momentum
because this this is you're an
incredible niche and your future is
super bright i think we've i know we've
talked before
but maybe we talked about do it on a
dime before you know
the economy's been in a weird place but
do it on a dime we interviewed on video
influencers away
a while back her channel blew up during
the recession of 2008.
so people need it right now since we are
in a recession pandemic and kind of
but like who even knows what's about to
happen and so they're
not only when you're building today but
as you're you know
consistent today you're very positioned
for especially extreme economic
downturn and your whole library of
videos will be lit on fire and that's
what ended up happening to her
and so um you know those are some of the
things i would recommend
and then lastly yeah i think getting
people on your insiders list
would just be you have a chance or if
they're on your email list they might be
on your email list
specifically voting this is a huge key
also back to
oliver's question how the conversation
and the relationship starts is important
if you set if you tell them like how
many times you're going to email them
what they can expect from you and just
so that they're not
like some people might want daily best
deals like potentially i want a daily so
i could just peruse the deals and those
could all be affiliate links or
and that takes energy it's my weekly
roundup
of the mo the best deals on the internet
i think the key there
is maybe only some of
your frugal living community would want
to opt in
tell them exactly what it is hey you
know friends i've been passionate about
this because
for some of us you know we like shopping
online we're always looking for the best
deal and the way i release youtube
videos i'm not able to always
um you know get information out right
away so i'm going to do a weekly roundup
this is only for you if you want to hear
about the products
i love and i use and that are the most
frugal options if you would like me to
send you
my some tips to your email inbox and my
favorite
products every week that's why how the
relationship starts is so important
because someone goes uh i don't i don't
want you to tell me about products great
hopefully they don't opt in and someone
goes oh that sounds awesome like i would
love to just have
amy do the work and send me uh
like and again it's just an option just
send me her recommendations like oh cool
i didn't know
that those oven mitts could be such a a
deal
boom a sale happens and you could build
up that email list
and um and yeah that's that's how i
would talk to him always transparent
transparent set expectations invite
people
into you know what it is and just today
um someone asked on our gvm video uh
they said what about the elgato key
light and i wrote like a paragraph i
delivered
like i just broke it all down and i was
like well the key light air has a base
so i wouldn't i'd skip on that one the
main key light
does go to the desk but it's 200 bucks
and i said on amazon if you use the
coupon
the gvm light i just talked about is 30
bucks off it's 109. you could
you could buy two for the price of one
elgato key light and
the elgato key light does have kind of
better software and it works with the
stream deck
but the app for the gvms are great and
the build quality of the lights is about
the exact same
so i think it's a no-brainer the gvm is
the better buy
uh here's the link i put a little
asterisk affiliate link
so i'm being i'm adding real value in
the comments media
disclaiming that it's an affiliate link
being completely transparent
and then the reply i already got a reply
that video came out today
and the person was like thanks so much
is a very detailed answer
and in a way that's not necessarily
frugal because it's still 109
light but you get it no but it is it's
yeah yeah
because you're looking at the best value
for what you want to get
yeah 100 and they don't they don't know
i and i'm doing the research this is my
area of obsession
i've tested the elgato i've tested it
and then i was like and by the way both
options are great but like let's do the
math man this is the better buy
and so that's kind of how i see your
channel is
just being super transparent and this
brings us amy
as you kind of share any follow-up i
think the way you really win like if we
want to summarize this for everybody
watching and it ties right into this
video with affiliate marketing
is literally by putting in a lot of work
love heart and care for your niche
because that's that's with the gvm
you're serving because i did i did real
research the way you lose
is if you haven't gone to the ends of
the earth
to find the best deal like when i title
my video best camera for youtube
i'm obsessed with coming up with the
best answer to that question
and therefore or best budget cameras
thinking what's not necessarily just the
lowest price
it's also the absolute lowest price with
the the
bare minimum features to get the results
that i think are important on youtube
so all that to say is i i can already
know you already got 7 000 subscribers
that's already your spirit but you know
finally i would say don't be afraid as
you
start doing any kind of affiliate
marketing or even if you have people
opt-in for your
best products best budget products email
list here's the bottom line
amy and i know you know this as soon as
you start selling anything
talking about money doing affiliate
marketing creating an online course
i promise you at least five percent of
people
are gonna get mad people have money
mindsets
it doesn't matter how transparent how
kind
you're not pushing it you're like listen
uh here's some value and like i have
another thing and like it's up to you if
you want to get it
and they'll be like i cannot believe you
would
smell something and you're like okay i
mean all right i
you can't believe it and i i am so
offended
that clearly your agenda is you're like
well i said what my agenda was i told
you like i would
give you some value and there's no no i
told you
my best products email list i mean
the agenda was on the opt-in page like
yes would you like
my best products you know and so
uh anyways i i think that also having a
level of courage
that don't let one or two email replies
or comments i think there's wisdom in
hearing that feedback of like
hey that felt weird or that felt pushy
like that might you know
modify your message a little bit but
never let the clamor
of you know one two three negative
comments for people because
i promise you it doesn't even matter
what you do there's always going to be
someone
who's got an opinion or whatever um
realize that when you
truly serve people with value
transparency
and it's okay to make money in the
middle that's what people have problem
with there's some people
who think that literally we should have
everything in common
uh and just be at some level like you
know and it's like no dude there's such
a thing as like
adding value like your income is
correlated to the amount of value you
add to the marketplace
uh it's okay to support your family and
pay your bills and
never and ethically serve people with
products and answers to questions small
businesses
entrepreneurs valuable youtube channels
solve problems
for a profit and that's okay not
everybody agrees with that
so as soon as you if you everybody
watching if you want to have the courage
to do this full-time
you have to be willing to know that five
to ten percent of people
are always going to have an opinion
about what you're doing and you have to
press through that anyway when you know
your heart's in the right place your
mission's in the right place
when it's not that you're not open to
feedback but you know that you're
serving the majority of people
and you're staying on your grind and
you're in integrity with what's in your
heart
then just be bold about it and step into
another level of monetization
thank you that is pretty much exactly
what i needed to hear
the details and that information about
the fact that
as i do this people are gonna opt out
and to say things like that that helped
because i i wasn't sure
even now i get i get i had a person
write to me in all caps
i am sick of you telling people to
subscribe to your channel
that's like yes okay but that one i have
sean cannell's voice in my head saying
you have to tell people to subscribe to
your channel
so his voice is louder than yours so
that's what i'm listening to
yeah of course no it's fopo and if you
haven't seen the video we'll link it up
in the description and we'll put it on
the youtube card
hopo the fear of other people's opinions
this is hard man when you get out there
on youtube
and and uh when you do anything i mean i
think it was
uh aristotle who said if you want to
avoid criticism
don't do anything say anything
or be anything so if you don't want to
get someone saying
i am sick of the way you i mean you'd be
you'd be blown away by the amount of
emails and comments we get and mind you
it's actually such a small percentage
but my friend john acuff calls it haters
math
99 positive comments plus one
negative comment equals one negative
comment
haters math is i don't even see the 99 i
didn't see that 99
of people liked it i'm like why did four
people click dislike like what
is this a statement about my value as a
human being in god's eyes you know like
we start going crazy
about like allowing it to affect our
self-worth of course realizing that
maybe someone interpreted it wrong they
didn't like what we said that's their
opinion i can have my opinion as well
i want to encourage everybody it doesn't
matter what you do like if you say
something
be something and you do something aka
start a youtube channel
you assuredly are going to get people
that misunderstand you criticized you
and then especially as you step into the
realm of monetization because money is a
touchy subject
obviously when people are in desperation
or how they were raised or the mindset
they
have about it or what they assume about
you and people are not
judging you even based on you they're
judging you based on the way they see
the world
people are always viewing you through
their own filter
how could it be that i could watch your
channel and say
man i can tell your spirit is so
generous i can tell that you're such a
kind and loving person everybody
watching can
like they can feel your energy and i
could tell that you
are leading with service and you're a
servant leader and i can tell you put
excellence and value into your set and
into your channel and into your
thumbnails
and into the the succulents that are
behind you
and you're solving people's problems and
your videos are free they are
free content on the internet that has no
charge
for the viewer that is sick about the
fact
it's a free video don't watch it
if you're so offended like don't even
leave a comment just move on
the comments that are mostly negative
and hypercritical and come from that
place
say a lot more about the person giving
the comment than somebody else
because to be fair people that are in a
healthy place
are perceiving the world correctly and
they're like amy's amazing
yeah she has like a an email newsletter
where she recommends products and she
makes money off that
and in the next five years you'll make a
lot of money off that because as you
have 10 000 subs
twenty five thousand subscribers on that
email list a hundred thousand
subscribers on that email list
you have a six figure multiple six
figure business helping people with
frugality and that will offend people it
shouldn't
because you've worked your butt off
you've led with value
you've been transparent the whole way
have you been perfect of course not
and no critic in your comments has ever
been perfect themselves
interesting that they can cast the first
stone when like if you were to turn the
mirror back on them
it'd be a whole other issue but a lot of
times their small
youtube channel and their insecurity is
being projected
on to you so i want to just inject
boldness into you to say that
kind of comes with the territory but
like when you're in the right place and
i hope that
and think media and think marketing
coffee with kennel
typically we kind of connect with and
attract purpose-driven people
values driven people people who are
servant leaders who lead with love
and definitely want to make a great
living in the process
but they just understand the priorities
of all of that and so
you got to be courageous amy and bold
that as you grow there's thousands
you're called to reach and help
and there's going to be a few that
misunderstand you
that can't really you know get on board
with that
and you got to be okay with that in the
process because
at the end of the day this frugal living
information
for people over 50 is critical it's a
very important mission
and there's always you know going to be
opposition i think it was albert
einstein who said uh
the greats will always
face violent opposition from mediocre
minds
those who are pushing for dreams pushing
for greatness that have a big dream
that are really serving and leading
people those with mediocre minds will
oppose you and it's not trying to be
critical but hey blame albert einstein
uh but you know at the end of the day
you got to be on mission and so i hope
that kind of ejects is that helpful a
little bit
yes um everything about what you said is
really speaking to what i needed to hear
and i thank you for the detailed
information about how to proceed within
each video and with an email list
strategy that might work really well
and also just the specific bit of
information that as i
make this next step that i'm going to
gain people and i'm also going to lose
people and that's okay
that's super super important for me to
hear and i didn't even realize it until
you said that so i really appreciate it
and thank you so much for your time and
thank you for everything
i appreciate you amy you are awesome
thanks so much for coming on coffee with
kennel
all right we got keto dragon coming up
next but uh let me know
have you ever gotten a negative comment
on one of your youtube videos you ever
gotten a comment
that got underneath your skin matthew
yes people get so mad
uh the work doesn't magically happen
goods and services don't appear out of
nothing some people expect you to
sacrifice yourself for nothing in return
it's kind of crazy
matthew definitely knows it matthew has
been just an incredible individual
he came to our event growth video live
when we could do things and meet in
person
years ago and that was when matthew and
i first met in person
he's been a part of our uh video raking
academy for a while and he um he's got
an awesome channel
that helps people create music with the
npc and all kinds of stuff
and it's just been so inspiring to see
matthew just be bold
but as you step out i mean people are
going to criticize everything man
i don't like the way you touch the
buttons on the npc i don't like the way
there's cords under your desk
your cord should be clear i don't like
your i don't like your hair
why is your beard gray why why
the other day i can't remember they said
they somebody called me like benjamin
button they were like you look
young in your face but your hair
look old like because of the gray hair
it's like thanks that's encouraging i
mean
you put yourself out on youtube you're
getting information that's like it just
could be personal you know what i mean
you get
personalized uh the pastor at our church
jabin said this the funny thing about
encouragement
is that when you encourage somebody you
usually
just say great job oh awesome smash like
someone puts out a good video you put
like a fire emoji right
you're like that was dope and
encouragement
is usually general but the problem with
criticism
is that it's usually specific so the
reason criticism hurts us so bad is they
criticize the specific
thing about the video oh a minute two
minutes at one minute in 23 seconds
you said an hdmi output when it was
actually
an input why are you so dumb and you're
like
okay dude i'm sorry i said the wrong
input output of the hdmi but it's a good
point
because for some reason the critic
absolutely hones in on that exact detail
and the person encouraging is like bomb
emoji dog
so you're like cool but it's not as
specific and the lesson in the takeaway
is we actually need more encouragement
that's much more specific
what if we encouraged others in specif
in the same
l with the same level of specificity
that
others criticize just a thought little
nugget from uh city light church which
is our church
here in vegas matt how dare you not
speak perfectly exactly
if i don't have the perfect chinny chin
chin
hair done right and i have not perfectly
articulated the bitrate of the m6 mark
ii and the sensor size of one
inch 0.2215 inches then i am not worth
love from other people right
just too funny okay uh listen
um we're gonna
my man uh tell me about your channel and
uh
where are you where are you coming to us
from oh i'm coming uh i'm your neighbor
i i'm here in vegas um and uh
right glad it's finally warming up a
little bit
but um no my channel is about the keto
lifestyle
um a couple of years ago i was 350
pounds
down uh down 100 pounds i feel better
than i've ever felt before i'm able to
uh
play with and take care of my kids so
it's
definitely something that uh i am very
passionate about
and as you can see i am a very new
channel
i love it well that's awesome and
congrats on that progress that's amazing
and congrats on
your vision or i just love your vision
for family and
for uh getting healthy that's super
inspiring um
what's your question today how can i
help well so
i'm definitely nowhere close to uh being
uh
monetized yet um even with uh
affiliate marketing i think i'm still a
little too early i do have a
an associate account and you know i
throw things out there but that's
definitely not my focus
my focus like you've said in many of the
vre
videos is to build my influence right
so i have joined several of the
keto facebook groups um i'm really
active in those
i've created my own keto facebook group
uh i'm in the process of building my
website i'm also a web designer and a
graphic artist so um that stuff's pretty
easy for me
but um my question
kind of comes from um
discord i don't i don't know if you're
familiar with discord but it's
uh primarily for uh gamers but i have
used it
very successfully to help organize
conversations for
a number of different types of
organizations right
and i was thinking of creating a
keto dragon discord server and
um actually calling that out to my
viewers
and calling it out to uh different
places out there in the community
to try to really organize and
better build my influence through just
building a community
around what i'm doing um i've
actually i'm in the process of writing a
book about my own particular strategies
on doing keto that i'm planning on
selling at some point or another
but um i've kind of gotten mixed
um mixed feedback about
um whether or not i should call out to
say a discord channel in my videos
because that might be taking away from
some of my um
[Music]
engagement there we go that's the word
the engagement from my youtube channel
itself
yeah yeah okay cool well uh love what
you're doing
and here's what i'd recommend i think
that uh
the discord server is a great idea the
book is a great idea
but i think you know really winning
online is about doing
not just the right things but the right
steps
in the right order and i want you
doubling down more
on youtube while we're in the process
and you know specifically
uh a things are going great i mean you
grew 37
subscribers in the last month so that's
epic you're hitting a video a week
you got 528 views you're very early on
with only six videos posted
but i would love to see some cover art
maybe
um level up your avatar and level up
your
thumbnails a little bit and then keep
pumping out quality videos
and here's the step-by-step series to do
it
first of all over on think media now we
have
a video that is one minute longer than
toy story uh right
it is uh but that nolan did on how to
set up your channel build a cover make
um
thumbnails and whatnot and it's it's the
how to start and set up a new youtube
channel
toy story is one hour and 21 minutes
long
this video is one hour and 22 minutes
long so you could either hang out with
woody and buzz lightyear
or you can hang out with nolan on the
think media team woody might be more
entertaining
but nolan mult's gonna help you make
more money and grow your channel faster
so
um this you can skip around there's time
codes in the video
and so you can skip to the certain
particular things
in regards to uh adding tags a lot of
you probably have a lot of that stuff
adding chapters
about how to make an end card end cards
for youtube
uh how to add a subscribe button
watermark so i would like to see some of
those details
um leveled up on the channel and then i
also really want you focusing on
thumbnails so if you go to think media
thumbnails
um this particular video right here
this is a good one that heather did she
uses canva
uh but the other one i like i think
nolan did a video
um and i'm not sure if that's we put out
a lot of videos we have this channel
yeah the channel r1 so that's a part of
the longer video but that get that
channel art up there and very easy to do
with canva
he breaks that down and then and then
maybe there isn't a thumbnail but he's
about to do a thumbnail series so watch
heather's video on thumbnails
some of those tweaks would be huge and
then pumping out
more videos i think writing the book is
great the sooner you have a buy button
aka your book
the better for monetization but just to
take a page from maybe what we learned
with youtube secrets
we actually all on youtube
for two years the book actually ended up
taking a little bit longer but our our
strat like from the beginning
we knew we wanted to do youtube for two
years at least a video a week
focusing on the best content possible
and building an email list mind you
because we figured anyone who signed it
up for the email list and by the way
2021 a discord server is kind of like an
email list
like an email list could be a discord
server a slack channel
um it could be a text message you know
if you use something like community to
build up text message phone numbers
i'm not suggesting anybody listening to
this do some of those other methods
email's still probably one of the best
but what you're what you're trying to
build
is a group of super fans those that are
more interested
so that the day your book comes out uh
or whatever your whatever comes out your
product your online course your t-shirts
your merch
you're like hey y'all those who care at
a deeper level
send email post discord post so it's
always good to diversify and build
audiences other places
but in my opinion um i would
maybe even for the next eight uh
videos for two months focus on like
making your channel beautiful leveling
up the channel
focusing on great videos just to kind of
put like some discipline
around the phases and if you're watching
this i want to challenge you to do the
same
um is to think about okay what are my
next five to ten moves
eventually i want to start that email
list build that online course write that
book but if that's move seven
nine and ten what are your next one two
three moves
make sure you're consistent and you've
been consistent on the videos but like
really get the youtube channel going
maybe say even a target i wanna get to a
thousand subscribers and then once i get
to a thousand subscribers
i wanna start the discord server so you
actually on paper
plan out not just the moves but the
timing of the moves and which one should
happen first
second and third and to me that's really
where the leverage is because what can
happen
is you start the discord server which is
a good thing
but good is the enemy of the great and
now there's so much
vibe happening in there that you go in
there every day and you are helping
people and creating intimate
relationships
but they have so many needs and
questions and you are like okay well
i spent all morning doing the discord
server i'm kind of behind on my youtube
videos
makes sense so what ends up happening is
now
you're already spreading your energy too
thin when you're only like six
eight videos in right and so to me
to get the momentum on youtube it's
really say okay my next move
is to watch the think media particularly
thumbnail cover
art optimize channel build some
playlists
think about my next series and you're in
vra so you have like the fast track
really you know go deep in vra and and
discipline myself and then say cool like
it could wait you should start the
discord server
start it may may 1st
and as like kind of like a reward and a
next step and you're like no okay i'm
going to start that there
and what i want to have happen by then
is i'm going to get this goal done that
goal down and this goal done
and and then you're like i got a special
announcement i'm excited then you invite
the 600 subscribers that are now there
the 2300 subscribers now they're
into the next thing and you've
systematized and you feel a little bit
more comfortable with your content
calendar
and you've dialed some things in and uh
and then there's even more momentum on
the discord server just to summarize
is that what ends up happening when
we're in like a side hustle season we're
growing our youtube channel
it is very difficult to be writing a
book with some of our energy
and maintaining a discord server and and
engaging with people
and then some people here are on
clubhouse and they just wasted 25 hours
on clubhouse this week
and then oh and then you know over here
we're trying to be consistent on our
youtube channel
and then meanwhile we're trying to also
take care of our health and be with our
family
dude our energy is split in too many
directions it's spread way too thin
so what can we say no to today not no to
forever
so that we could say it's about family
and i'm gonna crush this youtube channel
and only study content that's gonna help
me crush this youtube channel
and get some momentum going here and
then once i feel a little bit more
comfortable just like keto once i'm like
i got a little bit of momentum
i'm going a little bit faster now i've
hit a target
now it's affecting other every area of
my life and the momentum of the youtube
channel
is even going to help when i get to that
discord season is that helpful
absolutely pretty much exactly what i
needed to hear
awesome well cool man hey i appreciate
you and i really love
what you're doing um and uh thank you so
much for coming on coffee with kendall
today
oh thank you uh coffee with kennel
smash the like button if you're here and
you've been getting
value uh adrian says dig in the scruff
thank you
my wife sonia said keep the scrub but i
clean it up today a little bit a little
shaved under here
shaved right here you didn't ask but you
know bring it in should i keep it
question of the day keep the scruff
or shave the scruff that is the question
uh hey today's coffee with kennel is
brought to you by
idea to income dot um if you
are looking for 10 of the best ways to
make money online in 2021 my friend
chalene johnson
she's been a business mentor family
friend she's like my big sister now
known each other for about five years
and uh her husband are like business
mentors
to my wife and i and our team uh her
and uh her son brock lives up in seattle
snowboard friend and we all
we snowboard but that's not the point
the point is
she is a ninja on social media and
specifically
how to make money in a lot of creative
ways
she's not going to be talking about
adsense she's going to be talking about
10 different ways to make money online
this year
here's the powerful thing about this
challenge it's a free five-day challenge
that she's doing
she doesn't really talk about youtube
you're here for youtube
i'm gonna help you with youtube right
and so
when you use youtube as your death star
of traffic
okay what what the heck was that uh
then two other ways of making money
online it becomes a
match made in heaven release so anyways
uh info in the description down about
that
uh does it starts in a few days from now
and i told her i'd shout it out
because she's one of the most legit
best trainers coaches
she's still she's built and sold
multiple seven-figure businesses
um and she's a fitness celebrity like
it's kind of weird because some people
they go you know chalene johnson i do
turbo kick i do piyo
i do turbo jam like i work out with her
in my living room
anybody know shalene johnson you ever
heard of it yeah anyways uh i did
income.tips check that out and uh
you'll love that um okay so
listen smash like we have a super chat
super sticker real life genius thank you
so much for the super chat appreciate
the love uh the vote on the beard is
uh keep it the once a month beard
i'm a beard man so i say keep it my
beard is long
i want to see how long it goes but
barbie says shave though so
so she says shave clean shave that's
kind of my thing
i mean i don't know how long it'll last
but dad bod fitness says that i'm
distinguished
hmm button that button up right now too
get a little more
get a little more distinguished with the
dad bod situation
someone asked here uh what are we
streaming with
and this software is called stream yard
so dope i have fancier stuff it's called
like vmix
kind of expensive and i'm pretty techy
you know as you can imagine like we get
it like you started think media
um but stream yard is just so easy to
use and fun to use
easy to like put up a screen like this
and you know
bring your comments on and schedule
posts and whatever
in fact i did a video if you go thick
media stream yard
um you can get a whole tutorial about
uh the basics right here complete stream
yard tutorial
and specifically how to set it up for
for youtube this video will blow your
mind
like in terms of the strategy the
titling
the details of exactly how you can use
stream yard
to go live just like i'm doing right now
upload your thumbnail ahead of time
i walk you through the whole
step-by-step process um
this particular software you can go to
streamyard.com but if you want to get
it's free but if you want to get like a
plan where you can do the
the branding like the little think logo
up here
like you could even just easily play
videos on the background and stuff like
if this is how i play my first video i'm
able to just do this
all right so uh this is i guess the
first sean thanks vlog
you know you just say well that's like
in the back all super easy
um the paid version is super worth it if
you want to build your battle station
start live streaming and creating
content like this
i'm live on facebook and youtube at the
same time right now what's up facebook
and so um it's pretty fun uh
thinkmediatools.com is where you can
find not just
stream yard but all the different tools
we recommend and i think we have ten
dollars off
on a on a paid version when you're ready
to jump in but definitely grab the free
version and try it out
that's goes 720p it's 1080p now i'm like
i was distinguished for a while but i'm
going back to the mint green
undershirt okay listen um
uh sheamus and ivan and steve
and we got tiffany uh i think we have
time for one more thing
here and then i would love to have
people on uh in the future
but we're gonna have uh bowie basics on
next i don't know if i said that right
uh we're gonna have tiffany on the
coffee with kendall's show tiffany
how's it going hi sean you said my name
right it's bowie so it sounds like a
buoy
um thank you so much for having me on
vra it's
it's got so much value and um i just
started my youtube channel i think in
june
during quarantine and so we can kind of
pull it up i had a
couple questions about like my niche yep
let's go
so i've been kind of experimenting with
lots of different things
and it started off with like home decor
which got some
really good views on it and then i
started going into design because
i'm a designer and i felt like that was
also pretty valuable
and then i also really like traveling
and so
i know that it's important to be able to
niche down but i don't know exactly
like which path i should go or if
there's some kind of way i can kind of
mix it up
so that it can kind of be like connected
to each other somehow
awesome um what do you want to happen
like what is the the vision for uh
would you want to stop designing day in
the life
uh make full-time income online i mean
is that the target
uh is it to support and maybe are you a
freelancer
meaning you'd want to get more clients
like what's the goal
no right now i'm actually working as a
full-time designer like a tech company
and so i really like this i think it'd
be great to be able to
for example um like i like being able to
to show people like places to go to
maybe do more
affiliates with like traveling or home
decor
things and so that's something that i
really like but i felt like designing
was something that
i got a lot of people talking to my
channel about that they really liked so
i kind of went towards more that
direction because i felt
it felt like it was valuable for them
yeah i mean part of it in my opinion
i think a couple things that we should
foundationally note
you you've got a lot of advantages
because you know design so your
thumbnails
are fire you are not only part of vra
but you've you've got kind of a sixth
sense i think for
video ideas and titling and then and
then your ability to create good videos
by the way just curious and maybe people
are wondering too what kind of gear do
you use because it's super crispy do you
shoot and edit the videos yourself like
what's like your
workflow yeah so i have a fujifilm
uh t i think t3 i just got xt3
and so i [ __ ] with that and then i will
usually edit my videos on final cut and
i use epidemic sound for some of the
music in the background and
i put my my font using final cut and
everything
got it so thanks for breaking down your
workflow really obviously crispy setup
and great end result epidemic sounds
awesome for music
so so saying that you're also ability to
communicate and create content
so you're in a situation where you
definitely have options in my opinion
yeah too many options and and i think at
the one i i think it is okay for you to
experiment
um because at your stage in your channel
eventually you can kind of pick a
direction and go with it
i think you just started some of the new
um
design videos and people said they liked
it but like success leaves clues and
your best stuff
is your apartment tour apartment tour
apartment hunting diy
home decor type stuff even working from
home
um and and even like custom signs so
home decor and things like that
but but at the end of the day it's a
matter of focus and trying to be as
personally clear
about what is your desired end result
and just to expand it to the
everybody listening that's a huge thing
to have clarity on
i mean we are um
able to reverse engineer what it is we
want to build and when you build a
personal brand or you build a pers
a brand on youtube what you become known
for
is what you talk about what you repeat a
lot the types of videos you create
and then eventually the types of videos
that break out so sometimes people feel
like they get into a pigeonhole because
they might have like a breakout video
and they didn't mean for that to happen
and that is legitimate
but on the flip side you'll never become
known for something that you didn't
talk about in the first place like it's
still your own fault like you talked
about that thing
so it it is in a way on youtube
up to you to create your own destiny and
build the brand that you want to build
so i'm recommending to try to get as
clear as possible
on what your dream situation would look
like the pandemic will eventually be
over
i know we connected on instagram so i
saw you just recently went to hawaii or
whatever you love traveling
i do think that it is if you set your
mind to it clearly you accomplish your
goals
so i think that if you say you know what
this is my ideal future this my ideal
youtube channel i would like to work
with travel brands
potentially like maybe be a travel
influencer uh
then i think you could do that if you
just put in the tenacity the grit and
continue to apply the best strategies
i think if you wanted to kind of do an
hgtv
show in terms of homes apartment tours
while traveling i think you could that's
would be on brand i think
i think in in a way and it'd be
different than what the the cover image
because to me
um i think people would love to know
airbnbs
tips on airbnbs let me show you this
place let me show you this hotel
hotel tour uh deals on travel
whatever and i don't even know if that's
what you're saying but i'm saying you
you could absolutely go that direction
key is i think um just having the
discipline to do it
and maybe you realize this but
conversely
if this is a phenomenal niche to do
design if you were to do ux design
how to become a designer maybe a little
bit
of vloggy type stuff i think silicon
valley girl would be one
just thinking about the bay area and
thinking about a little bit of of like i
moved to the bay and vlog stuff
meets like designer life like knowing
who you're talking to
and people that might maybe want to
follow in your footsteps
in terms of that i think you could go
that direction as well
but to me and it's what you said this is
a pivot you pivoted in these last five
away from some of the apartment tours
and the christmas
decor type stuff um and so it comes down
to like an
issue of focus and i i'm sure you
realize this but
you know you have so many options a lot
when i really ask like what is it you
want to do what what is your
if you had to pick design or travel or
home decor like if you had to pick one
which one would you pick
probably travel and home decor i think
that like my dream
basically would be able to own and
decorate a bunch of airbnbs
and be able to kind of if i had like
this explosive youtube channel kind of
use that
um to be able to basically market my
future airbnbs
or being able to work with travel brands
and as well too so i was actually
thinking about
starting to do not just home tours of my
apartment because i'm starting to run
out of things to
tour the place but also um touring
airbnb so i stay in what do you think if
would that like connect with each other
i think that i love that number one
when pushed you articulated your dream
think media crew tell me in the comments
what is your your
ideal dream and tiffany you said i want
to own and decorate airbnbs
that's the most beautiful sentence ever
because it's just clear so that would
say
you just work backwards from that and
you just
asked do the videos align with
or then you just say is this on brand
for that or off brand for that
i think you can play a little bit
because i think
if you were to even travel and do like
five hiking
tips in an area near an airbnb as people
follow you
you start thinking about the person
you're talking to the person that wants
to go cool places maybe places you're
going and things to do that you're
showing them
the person that wants to to to find
airbnbs and learn airbnbs and as
you're really in a way making videos for
yourself like
that the things you dream about and read
about and research
and that your hobbies uh and the things
you love you're you're sort of
scratching your own itch and not every
video has to be liked by everybody but i
think it
what it does exclude is it excludes
um five free design tools like you know
and it doesn't necessarily
exclude five airbnb
3d rendering design tools because it's
on brand for maybe somebody else that's
going to set up an airbnb
and so um in my like the way you said it
to me it's incredibly clear
it's not what this says it wouldn't be
live from the bay
and it wouldn't be design it would it
would be kind of this
uh modern traveling
um airbnb uh
owner slash people who want and and
similarly my wife and i
are are also kind of getting into this
same thing and so
all of a sudden it opened up all these
needs best
decor ideas themes we had to save on the
core
tax write-offs uh for airbnbs
uh and and how does that all work and so
in addition to what you just said you
know could i document my journey i think
yes and i think that's
i might even think about having a one
day a week show and i know you also do
the vlogs
where of course you're weaving in your
personality and people are getting to
know you and they learn
your journey and you're documenting that
but i also think there's a whole list of
videos
you could do that are like five things
you should know when starting an airbnb
10 tax advantages that airbnb's didn't
you know and and then that like as far
as growth things get super interesting
like airbnb tax
tax write-offs like let's just see
you know seven thousand views here three
thousand
a hundred and twenty six thousand no i
take it back it's 126 views uh but
you know nevertheless uh 18 000 views
this type of uh content
that is it could be search based and
then
when it's search based you might you
know do the opening and do kind of the
vlog style you already have
the aesthetic vibe but then you deliver
on the promise of is that making sense
is that helping
unpack the idea a little bit yeah i
think you're kind of like going into
valuable content that you can do with
airbnbs except i'm not there yet i don't
have an airbnb
so i'm trying to figure out how i can
get to that level eventually
yeah and i think you know it makes me
think of like showbie church which
obviously
much bigger channel but she uh she did
like this house where she's like i
bought a house
why i didn't buy in los angeles so i
think
it's in my opinion i think um
when you buy your first one documenting
that lessons that i learned
and to me this is about catching vision
for the journey because you know how
much hard work success takes you've had
to put in so much hard work to get where
you are at this very moment
in your career so the five year vision
from now
five years from now you've added one
being airbnb to the portfolio per year
um people have grown with you on the
journey people have grown to think media
on the journey they're like bro i
remember when you had 38 000 subscribers
man it's been crazy to see
so like it's it's all brick by brick but
i think
um and and i think there's some
experimenting along the way yes
by the way like it's this this is how
you start thinking out of the box
you if you haven't done it yet meaning
you're not a results expert yet in
regards to airbnbs
then you collaborate with others and you
do
an interview show like like you do a
video podcast
once a week on your channel um you may
be even in the because of course you can
do zoom
easy and pandemic but like you also
in the bay area and when you travel you
could do more stylistic in person types
of things
and not only that growth hacks a lot of
things
when you do a show like that
you build relationships you get insider
knowledge you don't only get to ask
experts the questions and get that
intimate time with them but the
20 minutes before and after the
interview you're getting even other
things
you're getting deals brought your way a
lot of serendipity happens your network
and your world is expanding
but in the meantime yeah how do you
share be an expert today if you don't
have the results yet you bring experts
onto your show you platform them but you
platform them
through all of the design and all the
style that you have so that's just
another option
but i think the key that i love that we
got it
got clear on here is that if you know
that you know that like i want to own
and decorate airbnbs that is like and
that
five years from now i'm gonna have five
units all rocking
and i'm gonna go on this journey and
videos
they could be about the best
coffee maker for an apartment or an
airbnb
like if that's still on brand because
eventually someday
when we set up our airbnb that we're
doing in seattle in the next year
we will we'll have a keurig in there for
people like whatever
so like it could be a very specific
product or it could be something about
the core i think some of those things
still fit
within the reason someone was subscribed
that's up to you to keep honing it in
but man it's so powerful to get a clear
vision of what your end destination is
because now uh you just can work
backwards from that
experiment along the way try different
content formats
by the way if you start an interview
show like you don't have to sometimes we
think we start something
and we have to uh commit to it for the
rest of our lives
you could just do like a 10-part series
you're like hey guys i decided i'm gonna
i
wanted to find 10 people who i could
learn about airbnbs from
and now you put it all in a playlist and
you start it and you stop it and it's a
limited series and it's on your youtube
channel and that brings serendipity and
it brings people into your world
and you start something you saw you know
i'm the type of person that's like if we
started today
my son better take over this video
podcast like not everything has to be
forever
but you could experiment on the journey
all reverse engineering back
from i want to own and decorate airbnbs
got it thank you so so so much this
honestly was super helpful actually i
needed to kind of
talk it out and then i figured out what
i really wanted to do
i love it tiffany hey i'm so pumped
you're part of our community and i'm
excited for the next five years
and next 10 years because um heather
torres too
is were she's reading books on like how
to buy real estate with no money and all
kind of you know
uh airbnbs and traveling my friend brock
johnson was sharing
he was a sharon tips uh who's on the
idea income
uh tips challenge right he was sharing
uh him and his wife are just getting
airbnbs and they say what they look for
they talked about the
pros of being in an airbnb instead of a
hotel doc and this is on instagram
stories which is his main platform
but he was like uh board games more pet
friendly
um usually more of a diverse experience
uh kitschy cool places and i remember
like it leaped off the screen
when he put certain topics out like that
so i do think
there's so many unique things you can do
once you let your brain just kind of go
with video ideas that can
be on brand um so even before owning one
shopping for one getting the best deals
10 things you need to know about airbnbs
and as we just land the plane you know
these types of videos
like airbnb let's see
uh tips we'll go tips and that's for new
hosts you're not a host for guests
okay so airbnb tips for guests
and tips for booking the perfect airbnb
20 000 views she only has 3 000
subscribers it really stands out if
you're getting more views than
subscribers
because she's put a great video together
you could do this and don't feel like
you always have to travel
i wonder she might just be pulling
pictures like let's
look so she might you could do this
talking head from your house
it doesn't have to be your vlog footage
it could be a little bit of
a google screen it could be sharing your
screen and teaching
from your screen see and i mean it's 20
000 views so you start getting into this
and you start building up that tribe of
travelers
of airbnb i think you also uh play
around
with vrbo i think like our alternatives
to airbnb
like it's all the same kind of mentality
in audience
and same thing here we're talking head
we're at 6795 views
so so s like in fact this is kind of a
cool just
as we land the plane encouragement i
would encourage you
to sometimes uh
your production value actually could be
a hindrance to you at times
because you're a designer and i want to
encourage you
your your videos are amazing your
ability to produce
something really amazing is is something
you should lean into
at times but i would imagine
you would maybe be a perfectionist in
some areas is that true tiffany
definitely perfectionism is the enemy of
execution done is better than perfect so
i don't want you of course to sacrifice
that
but i want when you start a youtube
people
some it doesn't matter how cool the
intro and how like clever the music was
they do want the value which helps you
potentially scale more
you're gonna have plenty of times for
when you travel to like drone footage
and like amazing production value
that is one style of video but i
actually want to encourage you it's
interesting we kind of
because because these top-ranked videos
don't have
your design prowess they don't have the
openings
of the the reveal shot with the fuji xt
whatever
but yet they're getting the views it's
about content value not production value
just to encourage you
you could pump out a ton of volume there
might be the day where you sit down you
shoot four videos
tips for guests lessons i've learned you
know you go up here and you figure out
airbnb
tips for guests tips and tricks for
guests is like another part that you do
and um whatever and and that those
videos might be
easier for you to make and
this one has 86 000 views
oh and only 552 subscribers here so
uh you know shot vloggy style
and and delivering some tips apparently
only two minutes and 38 seconds success
leaves clues
so as we land the plane now that you
kind of have you know a lay of the land
if you will
i think it's i would potentially study
some of the top ranking videos what's
out there
what are some of the video ideas and
while i do want to encourage you to of
course be yourself
deliver your design skills and your
videography skills
but sometimes be willing to strip down
that production value for speed
because that's going to help you grow
faster it's still going to deliver
audience
uh deliver value to your audience um and
help you get those subscribers
and uh just a little thought is that
helpful yeah that's helpful
i just have to make sure i'm not so much
of a perfectionist then
yeah it definitely is something that uh
once we get a skill like you have
we can uh we can all fall into but hey i
appreciate you tiffany thanks so much
for coming on coffee with kennel
thank you thank you so much
all right friends uh smash the like
button listen today's episode is brought
to you by idea to income dot
tips uh if you haven't signed up this is
a free five day challenge
by my friend chalene johnson 10 ways to
make money online in 2021
if you pair this with your youtube
channel one
two punch uh you'll you'll love it and
uh she's
a great friend and business mentor
coming up starting in a few days
um if you haven't listened to this
week's
podcast you got to check us out on the
think marketing podcast
whether you're working out walking the
dog
flipping the flop whatever you're doing
you could throw in some earbuds and
either listen on apple
spotify google android uh or
um right here on the think marketing
youtube channel where we record think uh
coffee with kennel show it's uh the
video right before this one
and this week actually brock johnson um
talked about how to build your
confidence on camera if you want to
build your confidence on camera
if you want to overcome even some
mindsets needed to build more
momentum in business brock and chalene
are teaching on the challenge so is
brett her husband one of the most legit
business dudes i know anyways check out
the podcast
this week uh let me know what your aha
moment was
from today did you learn anything did
you get value out of
this session barbie got the flip in the
flop
value i'm glad that i could be here to
help you flip the flop dip the dog
clip the clap and smack
the hat okay uh sometimes you got to
flip the flop matthew's right
i mean he's not wrong and
truer words have never been so said
before
so uh links in the description down
below if you want to connect with any of
the things uh you can check the comments
out the new think marketing podcast
how to be more confident on video for
tips for beginners really good i think
that will
uh be an episode that you love i'm
grateful for you
thankful uh to be here today on coffee
with kennel
2021 it's time to build it's time to
grind
time to get focused time to kill
distractions
um i love the conversation with tiffany
about getting clear
on your ideal end goal your ideal
vision and working backwards from that
you don't want to
climb to the top of the mountain only to
realize you climb the wrong mountain
where is it you want this thing to go
end up what kind of business
what kind of youtube channel what kind
of lifestyle do you want to build
work backwards from that those can be
overwhelming questions
um but they could be very helpful to
uh think about the brand the business
the channel the content the videos the
what do you need to be known for
type of questions and so um
definitely uh think about that and post
in the comments below question of the
day
what do you want to be known for where
do you want to go full time in what
what what what would be your ideal
youtube channel um
you could join the five day side hustle
challenge idea income dot tips
and uh love is beautiful i would
recommend stream yard it's easier than
obs obs has more features though
um so if you want to learn obs you could
do a lot more
but but definitely stream yard is user
friendly
and speed is everything man complexity
is the enemy of execution keep it simple
and keep posting videos my name is sean
cannell this has been the coffee with
kennel show
thank you for being here today and i
will see you in the next
coffee with kennel peace